was werden Sie dagegen tun wie werden
sie die Menschen schützen die hierher
kommen denn wer hier rüber schafft der
kann nicht ruhig schlafen in der Nacht
was
werden
solche Fragen hatte der Görlitzer
Landrat sicher nicht auf seinem Zettel
bei der Bürgerfragestunde zum Thema Asyl
im Kreistag
die junge Frau an seinen Mikro die ihren
Namen nicht nennen wollte hatte einen
wunden Punkt berührt die Görlitzer sahen
sich hier in die rechte Ecke gestellt
was nicht jeder einfach so hinnehmen
wollte
[Musik]
der Kreistag hatte sich den Einwohnern
des Landkreises geöffnet für Ihre Fragen
zu geplanten Flüchtlingsunterkünfte eine
soll direkt neben der Firma von Henry
Engelmann in Hirschfelder Rosenthal
öffnen wir werden den Unternehmer später
noch wieder treffen die meisten die
kamen trieb die Sorge denn die
Flüchtlingszahlen sie wollen einfach
nicht sinken wo sollen die alle hin was
soll ich hier werden also das beängstigt
mich eigentlich ja natürlich besetzt die
AFD das Thema in Görlitz prominent
vertreten mit dem Bundessprecher der
hier auch im Kreistag sitzt die nur
Propeller stellte sicher wäre schon
ängstlich hier ankam der sollte auch
ängstlich wieder nach Hause gehen
wenn die erste Mutter wenn der erste
Familienvater wenn das erste Kind
in diesem Landkreis
zu Schaden kommt
verletzt wird vielleicht sogar getötet
wird was geschieht dann den nüchternen
Zahlen fast 5000 Asylsuchende und
Ukraine Flüchtlinge leben derzeit im
Landkreis etwa 1000 sollen dieses Jahr
noch dazu kommen der Freistaat sucht
händeringend Unterkünfte und wie groß
die Not ist zeigt dass er auch den
Standort Rosenthal in Betracht sieht
hier in der früheren flachsspinnerei
könnten 150 Menschen Platz finden in
einem Ort mit 120 Einwohnern fast ohne
Infrastruktur mit Einfamilienhäusern in
denen oft ältere Bewohner und
Bewohnerinnen Leben manchmal auch allein
unten am neuste Ufer 200 Meter von der
Unterkunft Weg führen Henry und
Rosemarie Engemann ihren
veranstaltungsbetrieb seit Wochen machen
Gerüchte die Runde hier und genau es
steht auch jetzt nicht fest und gerade
deshalb blicken die enge Manns mit
sorgen auf den Sommer wir wissen ja noch
nicht was auf uns zukommt wie viele
Flüchtlinge kommen welche Nationalitäten
das kommen wir haben Angst davor dass
dass wir viel Polizeiaufkommen an hier
haben werden die Leute die Gäste kommen
zu um uns um hier ihre Hochzeit zu
feiern in ihren Schuleintritt zu feiern
die Geburtstage zu feiern unbeschwert zu
sein die Schulklassen kommen zum
Schlauchbootfahren zu uns und da haben
wir eben davor Angst dass dann hier
Polizeipräsenz da sein wird und
ich sag mal so
Flüchtlinge die keine Aufgabe haben und
daneben hier auch ich meine die dürfen
sich natürlich bei uns aufhalten aber es
soll unsere Gäste eben nicht stören
Rosental hatte schon einmal Flüchtlinge
beherberg damals 2015 auch damals in der
flachsspinnerei nur eine Minute vom
Gelände der engemanns entfernt
wie ist es denn da für sie gewesen
damals wir hatten damals auch schon
kleine Problemchen hier mit den
Jugendlichen die sich dann eben hier bei
uns auf dem Gelände aufgehalten haben
haben unser gastnetz benutzt
es war schon grenzwertig grenzwertig war
das und ähm und ich denke mal das waren
ja nur 15 das war ja und die wurden
rundum betreut das soll ja das Zehnfache
an Menschen kommen
und wie gesagt wir hätten nichts gegen
Familien eine bunte Mischung die sich
die dann eben auch sozial anders
aufgestellt sind aber wenn alles junge
Männer sind wird schwierig Ende März
informierte das Landratsamt die
Rosenthaler hier vor Ort im Gebäude der
Abend muss vollkommen aus dem Ruder
gelaufen sein das berichten Augenzeugen
wie Kai Gräber Presse Sprecher aus dem
benachbarten Zittau zu dem Hirschfelde
und damit auch Rosenthal gehören
insbesondere eigentlich bei dieser
ersten Veranstaltung in in Hirschfelde
selbst wo viele viele Menschen da waren
und auch viele da waren die
offensichtlich nur darauf gewartet
hatten sollten so einen Moment zu
bekommen
um den den Beigeordneten der dort als
Vertreter des Landkreises war
immer mit Fragen zu bombardieren Ihnen
dann nicht zu Wort kommen zu lassen ihn
also die ganze Zeit nie dazu machen ich
dachte jetzt fehlt eigentlich fehlt
jetzt nur das jetzt äh das jetzt
irgendjemand ringfrei sagt und dann und
dann schlagen wir aufeinander ein so
fühlte sich das einfach an und ähm ich
habe dort die ganze Zeit gedacht zu
lösen wir doch kein Problem und Probleme
sieht auch kein Gräber noch genug auch
er hat Fragen auf die er vom Landkreis
noch keine Antwort gehört hat Fragen zum
Standort Rosenthal zu denen die dann
dorthin kommen sollen und wie es dann
weitergeht die Frage dessen was was soll
denn die die Menschen die dahin kommen
dann machen in so einem kleinen Ort mit
einem Supermarkt und irgendwie Ärzte
Mangel haben wir sowieso schon bis auf
die Decke hier
so wahnsinnig viele Möglichkeiten sich
Freizeit zu betätigen gibt es eigentlich
auch nicht und auf diese Frage was
sollen die denn da machen wenn die dann
da sind gab es bisher auch noch keine so
echte Antwort also ich verstehe dass da
dass da durchaus Ängste sind Bernd
Müller kann das bestätigen der
Bürgermeister von Hirschfelde sieht
seinen Ort seit einem Vierteljahrhundert
immer nur schrumpfen von 16000 auf nun
unter 2000 Einwohner und in diese Zeit
in der gefühlt alles immer nur wegbricht
platzen dann die Gerüchte von einer
geplanten Unterkunft Gerüchte keine
Fakten und so grassieren hier Ängste was
wohl werden wird im Sommer wenn die
Flüchtlinge dann da sind Bernd Müller
begegnet ihn fast täglich und überall
z.B im Gespräch mit Verkäuferinnen im
Supermarkt
die sagen wir sind hier vier fünf Frauen
Abend sind das sind alleine hier hin und
was ist wenn ihr zehn Jugendliche
reinkommen und die wollen plötzlich was
haben und Zahlen am Ende was ja schon
vorgekommen ist und wie sollen wir uns
dort dann verhalten und wir sind es
nicht ganz sicher mehr das sind also
Ängste die hier hochsteigen und man kann
das ja noch nicht alles voraussagen was
wird
werden dort Straftaten vergangen wir
haben keine oder wie wer will in die
Zukunft liegen also die Glaskugel kann
ich nicht reinschauen das sehe ich nicht
aber die Befürchtungen sind da es sind
auch diese Befürchtungen die den Ton im
Kreistag setzen doch da ist noch mehr
ungefähr 20 15 wird geredet ihr müsst
solidarisch sein ja wie lange denn noch
wo soll ich das Geld herkommen wie wurde
die Versorgung der Neuankömmlinge
organisiert werden die bevorzugt dann
behandelt oder wie soll denn das
vonstatten gehen wenn wir sowieso schon
im Gesundheitssystem an der
Belastungsgrenze sind und das ist
Vorschlag ist sofort gegeben 150
Flüchtlinge es werden sich doch 150
Bürger im Landkreis finden die gerne
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen aber bitte nicht
auf meine Kosten
Bürgermeister Thomas Zenker managt
allein drei Flüchtlingsheime in seiner
Stadt und das weitgehend problemlos dass
die rechten Parteien dieses Thema so
besetzten dass nervt ihn zu Sehens zumal
der Landkreis dringend Arbeitskräfte
braucht zenkers Botschaft an die AFD
Liebe Volksdeutsche unter uns wir
alleine werden es nicht trocken dieser
Landkreis ist von Demografie geplagt
nicht geprägt geplagt ist das richtig
geworden und wenn wir anständig hat
bessere Weg finden dann können die hier
kommen und andere Politiker noch so
viele großforschungszentren hierher
bringen der Ruf der uns voraus hat
gerade wieder mal verstärkt der Abend
konnte nur die wenigsten im Saal
besänftigen den eins beschäftigt hier
alle was bringt die Zukunft was passiert
wenn der Zuzug von Migranten nicht
abhebt sie müssen sich doch noch einmal
klar morgen
weil Grenzen erreicht sind
humanit
[Musik]
einen afd-antrag die Aufnahme von
Asylsuchenden in Zukunft praktisch zu
verweigern lehnten die anderen
Fraktionen ab bleibt die Frage nach der
fehlenden Kommunikation der Landrat
sieht hier ein Dilemma
wie man es macht macht man es falsch
wenn man zu früh informiert und noch
nicht alle Fragen beantworten kann stößt
das auf Kritik wenn man aber dann zu
spät mit einer ersten Information kommt
dann ist es berechtigterweise auch
kritikfähig und von daher immer in so
einer Gemengelage die schwierig ist auch
Unternehmer Henry Engemann zeigt sich
nach dem Abend wenig beruhigt das
womöglich nicht sofort auf einen Schlag
150 Asylbewerber nach Rosenthal kommen
das tröstet ihn nicht sicherlich es wird
stattfinden vielleicht nur am Anfang mit
30 40 Leuten aber wenn diese Tendenzen
so weitergehen jeder prophezeit das Jahr
dann werden auch diese
Kapazitäten voll ausgelastet werden und
dann haben wir irgendwann 150 Asylanten
da bei uns
das wird so kommen
für die Unterkunft soll demnächst ein
Betreiberkonzept vorliegen vieles andere
ist derzeit noch offen das Thema es wird
im Landkreis erhalten bleiben